this is said to be one of the trickiest  test questions a pattern is made from  four identical squares whose sides are  parallel to the axes work out the  coordinates of Point C  point a is at six comma seven and point  B is at 38 comma 36.  the first thing we'll do is work out the  horizontal distance between b and a this  is 38 minus 36 which is equal to 32.  that spans exactly Four Square side  lengths so each square has a side length  that's equal to 32 over 4 which is equal  to 8. then going from point B to point C  we will go down two side lengths and to  the left two side lengths so we take the  coordinates of point B and we subtract  16 comma 16.  this gives C is equal to 22 comma 20 and  that's the answer